La siguiente línea pasa por el punto -5, 2,
ok, por este punto.
Y tiene como ecuación "y" es igual a 8/11,
esto multiplicado por "x" más "b".
¿Cuál es el valor de la intersección con
el eje de las "y" o "b"?
Bueno, lo que nosotros sabemos es que, éste
punto, debe de satisfacer esta ecuación.
Como este punto está en esta recta, entonces
debe de satisfacer esta ecuación.
Eso quiere decir, que cuando "x" vale -5...
cuando "x" vale -5... entonces "y" vale 2...
entonces "y" vale 2...
Y entonces podemos decir que 2... que 2...
estoy sustituyendo aquí... 2 es igual,
¿a quién?
Ah bueno, es igual a 8/11, ok, esto que a
su vez multiplica a "x", pero "x" vale -5,
ok, estoy sustituyendo estos valores de este
punto en esta ecuación,
y a esto le voy a sumar... déjame ponerlo
con este color... a esto le voy a sumar "b"
y esencialmente, lo que tenemos que hacer,
es despejar a "b", resolver esta ecuación para "b".
Y bueno, para eso, lo primero que puedo hacer
es reducir un poco esta expresión, porque
aquí me quedaría, 2 es igual a 8/11 por -5
bueno, pues eso es lo mismo
que menos 5 por 8 es 40
40/11 ok, y a esto hay que sumarle "b"...
a esto hay que sumarle "b".
Y bueno, como queremos despejar a "b"
entonces a esta fracción la voy a pasar del otro lado
y para pasarla del otro lado,
lo que voy a hacer es sumar de ambos lados, la misma cantidad, que va a ser 40/11.
Entonces esto me va a quedar 2, ok... 2 más...
más este de aquí, que va a ser 40/11...
40/11 ok, esto es igual a -40/11 más 40/11,
bueno, pues eso se va y solamente me queda "b", ok.
Y ahora, lo único que nos falta es hacer
la operación que tenemos aquí, con fracciones.
Y para eso déjame bajar un poco la pantalla,
ok...
y vamos a seguir el problema.
¿Cuánto es 2, expresado como una fracción
que tenga denominador 11?
Bueno, pues esto es lo mismo...
y déjame ponerlo con este color...
2 por 11 es 22... 22 entre 11, ok, y a esto
le voy a sumar 40 entre 11, ok... 40 entre 11
y con esto voy a obtener el valor de "b".
Pero bueno, esto es lo mismo que... 22 más
40 es lo mismo que 62... 62 entre 11... entonces
me va a quedar 62 entre 11,
y bueno, esto es lo mismo que el valor de "b".
¡Y perfecto! como ya tenemos a "b" entonces
puedo decir que la ecuación de esta recta
es, "y" es igual a 8/11 por "x"
y a esto le sumamos "b"...
más "b", que es 62/11... más 62/11.